hello everyone and welcome to the final
day of the championship showdown the
chess960 edition or the chest 9 LX
Edition it's Garry Kasparov vs. Fabiana
Khurana there are no more rapid games
only 8 blitz games to be played in the
final day and this is one of the games
the title is from a chest 24 tweet and I
thought it described the game very
precisely so that's why I used it and I
forgot to mention as I usually do in a
new month do check if you were
automatically unsubscribed from the
channel as YouTube will sometimes do
this if you if you never comment for
example if you're not active they will
think you are not a real person and they
will automatically unsubscribe you from
the channel so if this happened to you
you are welcome to subscribe back that
being said let's check out the game
because part with the white pieces opens
with c4s he does in all the games he
doesn't play c4 in all the games but he
wants the free his Bishop repair as soon
as possible with c6 by Caruana Knight to
f3 and now F 5 by Caruana
d4 Becca's part of now freeing the dark
square bishop as well in the now d6 we
have castles by Kasparov and Knight to
f6 with b3 preparing TV and get to the
dark square bishop and Fabi also castles
with the shop to b2 and here as part of
Bishop there is really awesome that was
an accidental error and if Caruana tried
to do the same thing it wouldn't really
work out because he already played this
f5 move and he no longer has the
opportunity of just leaving it on
attained for example if Caruana tried b6
here at the fianchetto his Bishop the
same way casparo would continue night c2
he wants to bring this night over to III
and go after the f5 pawn and for example
there should be seven you could go
Knight e3 attack the pawn and now if you
defend it for example g6 now you get d5
and you completely block this light
square bishop so it's really out of his
place there and you've nicely freed your
own dark square bishop so here a Fabi
tries a different path of development
the knight to the c7 and now g3 because
part of prepares to bring the Queen into
the game with
six taking away the G five squared from
black from white also preparing g5 as
corona knows that Kasparov is gonna play
Knight see 293 and go after the pawn he
wants to play g5 and prepare f4 nice to
see two by Kasparov and now g5 preparing
f4 with d5 by Kasparov now freeing this
dark square bishop on this beautiful
diagonal and now c5 and nice to e3 going
after the f5 pawn with the knight and
the bishop so here Bobby just advances
the pawn with f4 and now Knight to f5
and it's a really dangerous for a knight
on f5 going after the e7 pawn even if
you don't capture it white will play III
open up the e-file play rook e1 go after
the backwards pawn and it's really not
allowing you to develop any of your
pieces so Bobby decides to take that to
take the knight with Bishop captures
Bishop captures and now Queen to g7 and
Queen to g2 because part of now prepares
King g1 he wants to get his King away
from the G file if the G file opens up
he wants to be able to play rook to g1
with Knight Sita eh
and now comes came to h1 as planned with
g4 by Fabi
and the now Knight the h4 now that that
Knight is a dangerous piece that the
bishop can come to e6 would check the
night and come to f5 then I can come to
g6 really just in a very very nice
position for Kasparov with Queen g5
unpinning the queen but Kasparov pins it
again bishop the c1 now preparing to
capture an f4 with nice to h5 by Fabi
guarding the f4 square and now comes
Bishop to e6 also the thread is just
pick up the bishop I'll give up the
route for two pieces but Bishop to e6
check by Kasparov
with King to h8 and now comes you could
go Bishop to b2 right away with check
back as far prepares at first Queen to
e4 now the knight can come to g6 again
with check to win material soaking back
to g7 and now Knight f5 check with King
to h8 and now G captures on f4 first and
only then after the Queen moves is
kasper already to play Bishop to b2
check now you could go Queen to f6
to prevent Bishop here but you don't
really want your queen on the same
diagonal as the king
Rudy two can come then Bishop here will
just completely destroy blacks position
so Bobby tried Queens the g6 and the now
Bishop the B to check by Kasparov with
King to h7 and now rook the g1 finally
getting that rook to the G file and as
you can see this Bishop is x-raying that
g4 pawn the rook will capture it at some
point with Knight e to f6 attacking
Kasparov's Queen and now even though
Kasparov could just retreat he decides
to give up the bishop for the night here
but for a very concrete reason he plays
Bishop captures on f6 with rook captures
on f6 and I feel free to pause the video
and try to find this very concrete
reason Kasparov had for giving up his
well he's dragging while I give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent supporter of concrete
reasons and for those who just want to
enjoy the show
rook captures and g4 this is as far as
idea now of course if you captured the
Ruby you get Knight captures on e7 you
open up a discovered check you open up a
discovery against the Queen and now
you'd have to go Queen g6 now just
Knight captures the Queen rook captures
and Luke g1 you attack the pinned piece
and this is now all over
so after this route captain g4 Fabio of
course said I'm not touching that rock
he played the rook after Sonny six put
the idea that if look after Swindon rook
captures queen but Kasparov again said
Queen captures on e6 and now the problem
is if you trade Queens for example Queen
captures you get the D captures any six
and what do you play here
rook a fake you go after the night but
now just efore Kasparov is up the
exchange he he has more pawns and this
Bishop is really not looking all that
great white would be completely winning
here you'd have to play d5 to free or
Bishop but even with this pawn sacrifice
you're not really freeing yet because if
you ever capture for example there's a
character's on f4 you just get Knight
captures on e7 and now this pawn just
easily wins the game
you you can also attack the knight
and it's all over either the night will
fall or you will have to remove the
defender of the question but but simply
pushing the deep one just wins
so after Queen captures any sex Fabi
said okay I can't trade Queens we play
Queen captures rook but now comes the
idea Kasparov had a queen captures on h6
would check King Jade and now rook to g1
and it was in this position that
Fabiana Carano resigned the game you're
losing the Queen and you have no counter
play for example after Queen captures
King captures you can't move the night
as mate is being threatened if you don't
move it white will just capture it you
could try a six to try something to get
your rook into the game but even after
captures you still can get your look
into the game now rugby 7 as the pawn
covers that square so you're just
getting made in a few moves
so of course Fabi saw that after Luke do
you want he resigned the game and a very
nice 27 move miniature by the former
world champ chess champion Garry
Kasparov now the game end the match
ended yesterday end out of the 26
possible points Caruana 119 points
Kasparov won 7 points and it's a really
a crushing result in favor of Caruana
but if you look at all the games that
because part of had completely winning
especially in the rapid section as rapid
games are being pointed to points for a
win whereas blitz games are only one
point for one if we take into
consideration that Kasparov could should
have won the two games that he blundered
in a move and that one that he lost on
time in a completely winning position
and that he didn't lose all the games
where he was just better the result
could have easily been for example
something like 13 to 13 which is not bad
considering Caruana is a world number
two oh but I am and if you're wondering
yeah also I'd like to mention Khurana
was awarded $30,000 for this victory in
this match whereas Garr as part of with
the second place it got $20,000 and if
you're wondering why we were only
showing Kasparov vs. Khurana games well
that's because Kasparov only comes out
of retirement once a year and we never
know if this will actually happen so
when it does
we at least I enjoy those games and I
would like to check out as many of them
as possible and I hope you share this
feeling as I I've been only showing
those games for the past four days but
yeah yeah I do hope you enjoyed it and I
don't know before I wasn't really into
the chest 960 but here I really enjoyed
it and really after a few initial moves
after your castles is done it the
positions really resemble positions you
would have a normal chest so it's really
not all that big of a deal and already
you can see some patterns appearing in
the openings like first you want to free
the bishops and the Queen which would
you do in classical chest and I don't
know it seems seems pretty enjoyable
yeah so really I do hope you enjoyed it
and maybe we're gonna show a game or two
from the chess960 Edition I will check
on your suggestions if you if you've
suggested any and we're gonna take it
from there if not we're continuing the
capablanca saga we have to finish that
and then we're starting a new series so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Patrick pakoda
maximun holtam and Zhang Lu for its
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check too on my previous videos
you're thinking for watching and I will
see you soon maybe with a few more games
of this chess960 edition continue in the
capablanca saga and checking up on your
excellent suggestions so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day